doing be it yoga or
cooking or
martial arts or whatever it is and
martial arts is one of those things that
requires everything
total presence to do oh wow yeah so i
dig it wow
you're right that it is a discipline
yeah yeah it seems that's why i never
did it
that's why i don't have a belt yeah
the reason why i don't have any stripes
or nothing like that is because i know
how complicated it is your belly
refusing [ __ ] you matt
oh sorry what why why i'm sorry you i
thought you were attacked i was like
right now
you were attacking me i thought you were
literal i'm sorry you're right
i love you you love my body i love you i
love your belly but john you look really
on that color but
what are you saying that for so top or
bottom or both
the yellow or the the is that the light
hand that's
[Laughter]
but
would you say
would you say though because you haven't
seen me in a while yeah that i've
ballooned a bit
okay what was left be honest be honest
with me have i ballooned a bit
i cannot tell that's a lie
no it's not you really can't tell that
i'm fat
no oh thank you
because i can tell that you're skinny
oh yeah do you remember this oh i do
different body types oh yeah he has not
changed look at him the same dude the
same dude
is that real
i don't
remember no film this oh yeah it was
called
yeah
where'd you go
this is a
so paulie your house right yeah so wait
wait what what house is it this is above
the comedy comedy store yeah so paulie
owned
a garage
people still come up to me and talk to
me about this this bit bro all the time
people always say
freeze
[Laughter]
every time like once a month freezer
lapd
look look how fresh faced you were i
know
this is weird because this this this
sketch is a little bit of a
this conversation we're having necessary
now it's very weird right it's about
that yeah right a little bit our
conversation freeze lapd lapd
and you're telling me to uh
to go for it
you're telling me to do the accident and
all that stuff right and then you come
and you swoop in and get the [ __ ]
thing yeah but that louis anderson was
in that too right louie anderson what a
weird [ __ ] yeah that was such a that
was such a long time ago it was right
oh and remember i gave you an award
yeah i asked you to give me the award i
was like what award was it i don't
remember no tell me what i was telling
them about i don't remember i remember
being in a conference hall it was a lot
of asians yeah
and i was like
you want me to give you an award that's
why i was there right yeah i went up
there and i gave you an award i remember
you presented the awards to him i said i
i i don't remember my speech you said
something about my eyes
i recall that